from a fried chicken sandwich and coffee
to beauty and Retail we uncover the
surprising stories behind the world's
most successful companies their profits
how they've expanded and how they've
navigated a changing economic climate
our first story is about America's
favorite chicken fast food company
Chick-fil-A a business based on a secret
recipe
this is the Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich
which according to multiple industry
surveys is America's favorite fast food
visit a Chick-fil-A anywhere in the
United States and you're likely to see a
long line of customers patiently waiting
to order the restaurant's Flagship menu
item there you guys go thank you so much
my pleasure y'all have a great rest of
your day in part thanks to its famous
chicken today Chick-fil-A is the third
largest U.S restaurant chain by domestic
sales we're still seeing tremendous
growth in our business so far this year
we're up about 20 percent so how did
this private atlanta-based fast food
chain become one of the most popular
restaurants in America
this is the economics of Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A has long had a unique
approach to business that the company
credits with its success from the
beginning Chick-fil-A's business was
built on a recipe after testing hundreds
of methods restaurateur Truett Kathy
developed a faster way to cook boneless
chicken using a pressure cooker and
peanut oil it's perfect and so we've
kept that locked away in a vault and
we'll continue to use that same recipe
none of the employees have access to it
so it is still shrouded in a lot of
mystery there are recipe sites where you
can try to recreate it but they have
never put it out officially the original
chicken sandwich is the same today as in
1967. a breaded breast of chicken two
pickles both placed on a buttered
Toasted Bun
[Music]
Chick-fil-A has long taken Pride for its
commitment to selling high quality
product in fact Chick-fil-A's name is a
take on chicken filet with a capital A
at the end symbolizing top quality while
other fast food chains tend to expand
their menu offerings over time to
attract new customers Chick-fil-A's
business model has always been to
maintain a small menu focused on chicken
sandwiches they like to say it's simple
so they want to keep customers knowing
what's on that menu to be able to easily
decipher what they want we think about
the way that we serve guests that
consistency is really important that we
get hot sandwiches cold salads and just
tasty products customers seem to agree
since its Creation in 2015 the American
customer satisfaction index has been
dominated by Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A
often rates very high even though the
service and the drive-through can be
slower people are very happy with the
quality of the service they get in
general today many Chick-fil-A
restaurants use a practice known as
Upstream ordering where an associate
will take a customer's order while
they're still waiting in line to start
before the the pandemic but has really
proved very important to the pandemic
when they closed their dining rooms
which really meant the drive-through is
the major channel of sales so if you go
to a Chick-fil-A now in many locations
you will see workers out in the
drive-through with tablets and so
instead of speaking into a speaker box
and kind of mumbling your order and it
may be getting screwed up you're telling
this person directly next to your car or
what you want to ensure that quality in
every one of its locations Chick-fil-A
uses a different franchise model than
most other fast food chains unlike most
chains where the franchisee covers most
of the costs of opening the restaurant
Chick-fil-A owns every one of its
locations the company also selects the
locations and builds the restaurants we
really think that that's a key
differentiator in the way that we
operate we're not looking for a
financial investor or people that want
to buy a big market and open a bunch of
stores Chick-fil-A States on their
website franchising is not an
opportunity for Passive Financial
investment working from the sideline
lines or adding to a portfolio of
business ventures franchisees are called
operators and each operator is
hand-picked by Chick-fil-A after a
rigorous interview process Chick-fil-A
likes to say it's about like going to
Harvard MBA it can take anywhere from 12
months 24 months so you really have to
want to do this and be willing to go
through the initial paperwork but then
extensive interviews out of the more
than 8 000 applicants Chick-fil-A
receives annually the company only
selects about 130 new operators a year
that's an acceptance rate lower than
Stanford one of the skills that we
really look for is somebody that's
really good at developing people a lot
of the stores have over 100 employees
they've got to be really really good at
pouring in and developing people in
teams and Leadership teams if selected
Chick-Fil-A franchisees need only an
initial investment of ten thousand
dollars which covers the franchise fee
to become an operator that's much lower
than the startup cost for a McDonald's
franchise which requires a 45 five
thousand dollar franchise fee as well as
1.3 to 2.3 million dollars of additional
investment if they're paid 10 or 15
locations it's hard to have that market
presence and to really know their team
members and the communities that we
serve and we've got a lot of interest to
become operators and feel like that
model is going to be really important
it's what's gotten us to where we are
Chick-fil-A credits this Hands-On
approach with the success of its
restaurants which on average make far
more off of each location than their
competition for years Chick-fil-A's
footprint was mostly in the Southeast
but today they can be found across the
country they have about 2 600
restaurants throughout the country
they're also located in Canada and they
are opening in Puerto Rico we're opening
about 100 stores a year right now and
we've got a lot of growth potential here
just domestically in the United States
but we're also looking at International
as well since 2007 Chick-fil-A has
nearly doubled its restaurant count to
2598. compared to a lot of other chains
that's still slow like a Chipotle is
opening 200 of restaurants a year no
matter which Chick-fil-A location you
eat at the company says its values are
reflected in its day-to-day operations
very close culture they're also invested
in its values which they do say are
based on judeo-christian values which
you don't have to be a Christian to work
there but they do you know take some of
these basic values of humility and
generosity and and if you want to go to
a prayer service while you're there you
certainly can from its Inception founder
Truett Kathy's Christian faith played a
major role in the company's business
strategy it's why Chick-fil-As are never
open on Sunday not just so workers can
attend church but also so they can rest
in general we feel like we make up for
the sales in the Monday through Saturday
and that anticipation of ah I can't get
Chick-fil-A today so I want to make sure
to go first thing Monday morning it's
also the reason the company has never
gone public I don't think we will ever
actually I know we'll never go public
and there's not a real benefit for us to
do that we've grown conservatively and
so we don't need a lot of investors or
extra cash to go and to build new stores
or new businesses part of Kathy's values
are reflected in how employees are
treated and how they're expected to
treat customers thank you pleasure you
have a great day although you won't see
it in restaurants where the employees
are massed up Chick-fil-A has long asked
employees to greet customers warmly with
a smile even if it's just on a very
small interaction you can share a lot by
just the smile that team member has with
guests is just a small little thing that
we can do that makes a difference
occasionally Chick-fil-A's values have
attracted scrutiny especially when the
company's foundation donates to
conservative groups or causes there's
been some groups perceived as anti-gay
and this is a you know attracted
attention from Progressive groups the
company's foundation in the last year
has focused its charitable giving on
three different areas homelessness
hunger and education I think the most
important thing for us being in the
restaurant business is that we serve
everybody my grandfather I love how he
talked about it with politics he would
say I'm not right wing or left-wing I'm
the whole chicken when you go to
headquarters in Atlanta there is this
rock with a quote from Truitt that is
just played prominently that says what
Chick-fil-A's corporate purpose it says
to glorify God by being a faithful
Steward of all that is entrusted to us
to have a positive influence on all who
come in contact with Chick-fil-A I do
think that reflects this very higher
Noble sense of company self they have
they believe they do more than just
serve chicken sandwiches thank you so
much pleasure have a nice one if you've
ever shopped at Costco you may have
noticed that it's a little different
Costco is not engineered for a quick
shopping trip it is exactly the opposite
this is the economics of Costco it's not
a grocery store it's not a small corner
store it's huge it's cavernous the
ceiling is high goods are literally
stacked on pallets up to this almost the
ceiling that's all part of the model and
the experience I gotta cost
okay first thing we got is a five dozen
of eggs then we got salmon for you
unlike most stores there are no aisle
signs or in-store maps to help direct
shoppers
instead aisles are simply numbered
what's more Costco constantly moves some
of its products and Cycles in new
products
so what gives why are Costco's stores
designed this way and how has it helped
the company grow into the retail
Behemoth that it is today
Costco is a big fan of using treasure
hunt retail psychology to draw you in
which is basically having items on the
shelf that are at a like wow price
because they're such a good discount or
they're just really interesting and
they're not going to be there forever
the big idea behind Costco's treasure
hunt strategy is that by encouraging
customers to explore and ensuring that
there's always a new batch of
interesting deals customers end up
shopping longer and buying more products
today I went to Costco thinking I'm just
going to get a few items but I ended up
with a whole entire
when you go into the store it doesn't
feel the same as the last time you were
there so you have a sense of urgency
about purchasing and also just a sense
of wanting to come back right and check
out what's going on if it was the same
every time you might not come as often
today Costco is one of the world's
largest retailers boasting over 803
locations and 275 000 employees Costco
was part of sort of this early
Warehouse Club concept which was really
about instead of like go to the store
buy a single item come to the store pay
a membership and maybe your small
business and we'll offer you wholesale
prices basically lower prices
most members pay an annual fee of 60 for
the basic plan but customers can upgrade
to the executive membership which is
more perks for 120 dollars a year
membership dues are also how Costco
makes most of its money I think Costco's
Management's main goal is always this
ethos of can we offer more exciting
items at a better price
to keep memberships growing the model is
make money on the membership sell things
as cheaply as possible they can't just
raise the price on something to increase
the profit that's against the internal
code and so that also includes things
like let's save money and how much time
we spend putting products on shelves so
that's part of the reason why you see
these pallets of goods stacked up to the
ceiling is there's not a lot of time
spent taking apart those pellets putting
each individual product on the Shelf if
they eliminate that there's a little bit
of Labor savings there's some time
savings because they're just putting all
that stuff out on a pallet and you take
it Costco says that an average item in
the store is only marked up 11 percent
compared to the 25 to 50 percent often
seen in retail this commitment to low
prices hasn't just kept customers loyal
it has also helped spread the brand
there's a psychology to finding a deal
that's very satisfying for people and
people enjoy the product selection at
Costco they have very skilled Merchants
that usually have been employed there
for a very long time and really know
what a Costco customer likely would want
and they're good at getting good prices
on those products
I got your protein flavored vanilla and
that sort of creates a certain frenzy
around finding those things I got the
Kirkland brand microwave popcorn I got
two packs of bottled water most
retailers might assume the Shoppers want
more choices not less they sell a
limited number of items so that means
they have to be pretty precise they
think about like giving space to a
product in their store differently than
a Walmart would and if that product
doesn't sell like it's out of there it's
very Cutthroat if you're a product on
the Shelf you have to earn your place
the average Costco Warehouse stocks
about 3 700 products at any given time
less than one tenth of most supermarkets
40 to 50 000 items but even though
Costco stocks fewer items the items they
do stock have a reputation I see you've
noticed me rolling up the sleeves on my
new Kirkland Signature quarters that my
mother got me for the holidays Kirkland
is Costco's you know private label brand
it's their store brand it's a brand that
when they want to offer something at a
certain price that they don't feel uh
manufacturer A supplier can do it they
build it themselves since it was
launched in 1995 the in-house brand has
built a reputation for quality and low
prices on everyday items today Kirkland
products make up a quarter of Costco's
166 billion dollars in annual sales
but when you talk to customers I think
they generally feel that it doesn't
necessarily need to be fancy because
they've already bought into this Costco
pitch which is this is high quality and
it's a lower price and you don't need to
be afraid of it that Customer Loyalty
helped Costco remain strong during the
pandemic Costco is certainly a model
that has not only survived the pandemic
but has really thrived in the pandemic
despite the increased popularity of
online shopping Costco has leaned into
its strategy of driving members to its
stores it's it's really interesting to
me because for years people have
questioned Costco you know Amazon's
going to get you you got to get bigger
online and that really hasn't played out
yet they've said explicitly we prefer
people to come into the store and Shop
we want impulse buys we want people to
come in and see what we have and buy
more we work better that way and it's
cheaper
[Music]
if you've ever ordered something at
Starbucks you've probably loaded one of
these Starbucks between October and
December is set something like three
billion dollars of value is loaded onto
these cards I mean that's a lot of money
so much money in fact that if Starbucks
was a bank it would rank as the 385th
biggest in the country and it's money
that Starbucks gets to use up front as
Revenue before a single product is even
purchased eventually it is a liability
if someone chooses to use it and you
will find that in lots of gift card
programs they're planning people who
never use it so how important is
Starbucks's mobile app and gift cards to
its bottom line and what role does
technology play in its continued
evolution
this is the economics of Starbucks
in 1971 the first Starbucks a small
unassuming Cafe opened in Seattle's
downtown fast forward 50 years and that
store is still in operation but
Starbucks is a global coffee giant only
McDonald's is bigger than Starbucks when
it comes to market caps so they are
really a Powerhouse when it comes to
really the whole restaurant industry in
its early years of operation Starbucks
expanded slowly and only within Seattle
it wasn't until 1987 when the original
owners sold the company to its then
marketing director Howard Schultz that
the Starbucks that we know today took
root Schultz began expanding Starbucks
outside of the city and introduced
Americans to what was then a
little-known Italian drink the espresso
they were really founded on this coffee
house culture that they make each
beverage by hand according to order as
Starbucks has grown that has gotten more
complicated today Starbucks says they
make more than 100 170 000 different
varieties of drinks these beverages can
be very complex they can take a while
they can take many different ingredients
and so it's good for Starbucks and that
these tend to be higher priced beverages
but for workers the Baristas they can be
very complicated the company's early
investment in espresso has transformed
to many different signature drinks from
the creation of the Frappuccino to the
launch of the pumpkin spice latte
pumpkin spice latte High private they
really didn't know that it would take
off like it did but clearly it is formed
quite a phenomenon all around the world
really we introduced pumpkin to spice us
here Starbucks one additional thing in
Starbucks evolution is cold beverages
have become much more important to the
company whether it's just an iced coffee
or a Nitro iced coffee or all these cold
foam and cold brewed increasingly this
is so important to their revenue the
company's gone through periods where
Frappuccino sales have softened but
they've come up with more cold drinks to
keep people interested in keep people
ordering
in part due to the company's Seattle
founding technology has played a large
role in the change dominance a key
moment of that was the founding of its
mobile app in 2009 which was very early
for one of these kind of apps and they
really saw this as a digital flywheel at
the end of 2021 mobile orders accounted
for nearly a quarter of all Starbucks
transactions in the U.S many of those
purchased through a virtual Starbucks
gift card which was previously the only
way a customer could order on their
phone today a little under one half or
44 percent of all transactions at
Starbucks are done with a Starbucks card
in fact so many Starbucks customers use
a Starbucks card or the Starbucks mobile
app to purchase items that Starbucks
says it holds about 2.4 billion dollars
in cash that was uploaded by customers
to be used later that number exceeds the
deposits at many American Banks
Starbucks also gets a lot of data from
that they own a lot of that data in a
way that many companies don't because
they have created this whole ecosystem
where people are you know using the
Starbucks app their mobile ordering and
they're hooked into that Starbucks
unique proprietary system as mobile
payments rise Starbucks's business
priorities have shifted prior to the
pandemic approximately 80 percent of U.S
Starbucks transactions were on the go
either as drive-through or mobile order
Starbucks starred in cities but really
has spread all around the country
including suburbs and a lot of that is
through drive-throughs these alternate
pickup options are becoming increasingly
important to the company's bottom line
especially during the pandemic I mean
these stores have been a Lifeline to
Starbucks because they kept running and
people could easily queue up and go and
not have to enter an actual Cafe
Starbucks has long said that it remains
committed to a set of values established
early in the company's existence
Starbucks is very
committed to trying to create a
connection between its Baristas and its
customers even in its drive through they
talk about this on earnings calls that
there are these customer connection
scores they want to make sure that
everyone is feeling good about their
Starbucks experience which is getting
increasingly challenging when you're
ordering through a drive-through or a
mobile app you're trying to get in and
out Starbucks says those values also
appear in the manner in which their
stores are designed the items you will
find in the store they really
choreograph that down to where the
basket of waters is placed into a store
they want this all to feel very similar
Starbucks is long touted its internal
culture which it says is built on a
strong relationship between management
and employees the workers at its stores
are not called workers or Baristas
they're called partners and this is very
Central to the company's ideology part
of that is that all these Partners do
get shares in the company it's called
Beanstalk that relationship may look
different going forward for some
Starbucks locations after two of three
buffalo stores voted in favor of
unionization since then Starbucks has
thrown a huge amount of energy and
resources into this issue and Executives
have traveled to Buffalo extensively to
meet with workers to try to understand
their concerns according to the company
they want to maintain this direct
relationship with their workers they
call unions in intermediary they do not
want that relationship to be severed but
according to these workers they who
support the union they want a more
direct relationship with the company in
a statement to the Wall Street Journal
Starbucks said Starbucks's success past
present and future is built on how we
partner together always with our mission
and values at our core from the
beginning we've been clear in our belief
that we are better together as partners
without a union between us at Starbucks
and that conviction has not changed
they are the world's biggest coffee
chain they are very dominant when it
comes to Coffee sales and they are
really synonymous with coffee house
culture in a lot of ways but they do
face increasing pressures
[Music]
you know they don't tell you don't lay
on the bed
you're supposed to lay on the bed
if you've ever visited an Ikea you've
likely encountered their stores
endlessly winding floor plan this layout
can be confusing
that is by Design Ikea may be the
biggest Furniture retailer on the planet
but it's certainly not conventional the
Swedish Furniture giant asks its
customers to build their own products
and its stores and distributes those
products in minimalist flat packed boxes
so how of these retail strategies as
well as their famous Swedish meatballs
contributed to the company's runaway
success this is the economics of Ikea a
look at the innovative business
practices that have transformed Modern
Life
when you step into an Ikea you
immediately sort of are put
A's like
path
IKEA store layout is a fixed path design
which means there's a designated road
that all customers must follow that
guides you through the store in One
Direction
it's not a grab a carton of milk and get
out kind of store it's it's the opposite
of that
it's very much set up to spend a day
think about rooms you know dream about
what you really want your bedroom to
look like
a floor plan of most Ikea stores
resembles a maze the curves about every
50 feet to keep customers curious about
what comes next since an average IKEA
store is around 300 000 square feet or
five American football fields that means
a lot of walking an Ikea is to some
frustratingly winding but really it's
laid out as an experience to get you to
buy more
Ikea is famous for putting its customers
to work unlike most Furniture retailers
that sell products pre-assembled many of
Ikea's pieces have to be built by their
customers
but why as many couples and their
therapists well know building your own
IKEA cabinet can be challenging the big
idea behind the Ikea effect is consumers
are more attached to have more positive
feelings towards objects or things that
we've put effort into and that we
actually think that they're more
valuable because of that foreign
Ikea effect was first coined in 2011 by
researchers who noticed a similar
phenomena in other products and
businesses
when instant cake mixes were first
introduced in the 1950s they didn't sell
well and then they said let's add a
fresh egg it was this idea that we want
to feel like we're just participating
enough to not feel guilty about taking a
shortcut
when you make a cake from a mix which do
you want a fresh egg cake or a cake made
with dried eggs for higher lighter
tastier cake why fresh eggs of course
the idea that we should love building
products isn't necessarily what Ikea
intended
if you've ever shopped at one of Ikea's
massive warehouse stores you're likely
aware of the unconventional product
names
but what you may not realize is that in
creating these items Ikea sometimes
comes up with a price tag first sort of
a classic example that they could talk
about all the time is the one one dollar
light bulb if they had this idea that a
one dollar LED light bulb you know this
new type of light bulb would be hard to
achieve but if they could achieve it
lots of people would buy LED light bulbs
so they just sort of designed backward
from the prep with the price point in
mind that obsession with low prices is a
large part of why Ikea is the world's
largest Furniture retailer today Ikea
has 445 stores operating in 52 countries
you know obviously if you go into a
student dorm room you're going to find a
lot of Ikea but you'll also find some
Ikea products in a wealthy person's home
and that's really what they're going for
today Ikea is the very definition of
mass Market appeal but when the company
first began as a Swedish mail order
business in 1943 well-designed Furniture
tended to be expensive and as a result
Out Of Reach for most were seen as a
serious long-term investment
ingvar comprad who founded the company
as a teenager pushed forward the idea
that furniture could be flat packed to
massively reduce the cost of shipping
and transportation so flat packing is
really the largest arguably Ikea
invention that really led to the
company's growth and the idea is that
instead of buying you know a piece of
furniture all put together it's
deconstructed into a flat pack you can
fit more in a truck you can fit more in
the Ikea warehouse and you can also get
it in your car and the trade-off is you
know you put it together at the end flat
packing is a practical aspect of the
philosophy that has long guided Ikea's
success called Democratic design it's
this idea that everything is in Balance
both price form function the aesthetic
the sustainability this Vision to create
a better everyday life for the many
people was sent forth more than 30 years
ago by comprod in a Manifesto now
presented to every Ikea employee and
they talk about it almost religiously
and fundamentally it's this idea that
when designing a product they think
about
it can't just be really cool looking it
can't just be functional it has to be
all those things
so despite the long shopping trips and
the DIY
customers can't seem to get enough of
Ikea
perhaps it's as simple as labor leaves
to love they are so cute and they even
smell like the cereal y'all Crocs the
colorful shoe that first became popular
in the early 2000s hit its peak in 2021
the company reported a record annual
revenue of 2.3 billion dollars in 2021
up over 60 percent from the previous
year and its stock reached record highs
the past few years for Crocs has been
this moment of heavy collaboration
constant releases they're really trying
to put themselves in front of people
that might not have considered a Crocs
prior
the company's success coincided with the
pandemic leading some to credit the
shoe's popularity to timing especially
as its stock price has been dropping
since the pandemic boom has waned but
other comfortable Footwear Brands didn't
take off the way Crocs did so how did
Crocs make a name for itself during the
pandemic and how did it find success as
one of Fashion's most divisive shoes
this is the economics of Crocs
the company was founded in 2002 the same
year it debuted its classic clog the
name Crocs was inspired by crocodiles
who live on land and in water when
cracks were first released they were
intended for a consumer that was looking
at them as a functional thing so
probably gardeners people that you know
were on boats people that worked all day
on their feet people that worked on a
line in the kitchen part of what makes
them so functional is the material a
proprietary closed cell resin called
crosslight that's slip resistant
lightweight and easy to clean producing
a molded shoe is certainly simpler in a
lot of ways than assembling a sneaker
the most underrated Advantage they have
over the marketplace is that it's clear
that they're able to kind of do things
that other companies would not be able
to do because of their scale and because
of their production capabilities Crocs
sales took off in the first three
quarters of 2005 it sold 4.4 million
shoes hitting a revenue of 75 million
dollars
part of the reason for its initial
success was that the shoe was easy to
get it was available at retail stores
gift shops and mall kiosks in 2006 Crocs
purchased gibbets a company that made
small plastic shoe charms that same year
the company went public and became the
largest ever U.S footwear IPO at the
time but in 2008 in the midst of the
financial crash the company suffered a
net income loss of 185 million dollars
though the initial crates had simmered
the brand still managed to hang on to a
relatively large customer base over the
next few years thanks to its Global
presence in 2014 Crocs started making
major changes to its business model
closing dozens of stores shifting away
from malls and turning to online sellers
like Amazon Crocs announcing today it
will eliminate nearly 200 jobs and close
a number of retail stores as part of a
restructuring effort the company also
cut back on the number of styles it sold
by between 30 and 40 percent and
refocused on the classic clog that made
it famous
the following year Crocs invested in a
Global Marketing push to relaunch its
brand image
despite its efforts the company's stock
held steady until 2020 when the global
pandemic hit prior to people working
from home and you know not wearing their
dress shoes not wearing their heels
there was already this Rising wave of
comfort-minded comfort first Footwear
that was really becoming more popular of
course that accelerated during the
pandemic the Comfort aspect is what many
call the key to crox's success but
another important factor is how easy it
is to customize the shoe with gibbets
you move them to different Crocs over
time as you've got a green pair a camo
pair or a pink pair that like the
gibbets would stay with you and they
were yours they were almost like uh the
way a keychain on a backpack was at a
certain point this idea of individuality
and self-expression is one that the
brand emphasizes through its marketing
campaign
and on social media the uniqueness of
the shoe's design has sparked debate
even going back to Croc's early days
there were two warring factions of Crocs
are ugly and they're a blade on society
and we need to get rid of them I don't
care how comfortable they are they're
ugly and then there were people that
said no they're cute and they're kind of
doughy and they're fun look how freaking
to you these are Crocs leaned into this
polarization partnering with celebrities
and well-known Brands to create limited
edition versions of the classic clog I
think that's probably the biggest shift
within the Fashion World of the past
decade is that people truly seem to
design for Instagram because you want to
stop people from scrolling and certainly
a shoe plastered with fried chicken does
that in 2018 Crocs says it's Balenciaga
clog an 850 4-inch platform shoe sold
out within hours and in 2021 Crocs says
it partnered with more than two dozen
Brands artists and creators through
collaborations and license programs
sometimes it was through gibbets but
sometimes it was like these kind of
crazy revamping of what their clog was
constantly releasing new collaborations
has not only kept Crocs in the Press but
it has also helped it break into new
markets there are like Croc collectors
that go after every model Penny I am
overflowing with Crocs the same way that
Nike's resell on websites like stockx
and eBay Crocs are now reselling Crocs
and other comfortable shoes may have
peaked with the pandemic as people begin
to migrate back into work and consider
more traditionalist Footwear but many
others are still prioritizing Comfort
we're seeing that with a lot of doughy
running sneakers that people are wearing
we're seeing that certainly with the
growth of slides is a huge business in
the luxury Market crox's stock has
dropped around 60 percent since its
November 2021 High I think the Market's
nervous about the short term right so
we're definitely seeing um Supply
constraints um in the first quarter but
the company says its fourth straight
year of Revenue growth was fueled by
continued Global demand and it expects
revenues to grow to over 5 billion
dollars by 2026. I think that the
tow at a certain point you can only
reach so many consumers but I think for
now they have been able to convince
enough consumers that they deserve space
within their closet and they gotta have
the two fingers
Dollar General's business model it's a
retailer that can make a lot of money
selling very cheap Goods to a relatively
small number of people if you've ever
shopped at a Dollar General you might
have found the store on a remote Road
like this one it has every appearance of
being in the middle of nowhere but this
is a meticulously planned very well
thought through strategy a strategy
that's been key to Dollar General
success in Rural America
the company is Bucking current retail
Trends by expanding rapidly and opening
stores away from population centers
Dollar Generals go where Walmarts aren't
but it's not just the Strategic
locations far away from big box stores
Dollar General employs a number of
tactics to keep operating costs down
including leasing stores paying
employees low wages and selling limited
products and yes that includes stuff
that isn't really a dollar dollar
general is almost something unto itself
it kind of takes pieces from a lot of
different retailing models this is the
economics of Dollar General after more
than 30 consecutive years of sales
growth Dollar General has become one of
the most profitable and fastest growing
retailers in the US last year the
company brought in more than 30 billion
dollars in sales so how has a store that
sells products at rock bottom prices
manage such extreme growth they add
about two and a half stores every day in
the United States just for for scope
there's more than four times as many
Dollar Generals as there are Walmarts
there's more Dollar Generals than there
are McDonald's in the United States
there are currently more than seventeen
thousand Dollar Generals in the US but
if you don't live in Rural America you
might not have ever even stepped foot
inside the store where would you
typically find a Dollar General you'd
you'd think of a two-lane road think of
you know places where the houses are far
apart farmlands kind of lower income
communities you might find them by a
post office or a church or at an
important intersection this is often a
deliberate decision the company has
formulas for identifying locations to
open stores often the Dollar General
will be down the road miles away from
the nearest town and Walmart areas with
limited shopping options
three quarters of Dollar General stores
serve communities of twenty thousand
people or less according to the company
it looks for need first and foremost so
it's going to look for a place that we
might call a food desert where there are
not there's not a grocery store there's
not a big box store it's kind of Target
demographic is households uh with people
making forty thousand dollars or less
and it looks for a place where it can
get inexpensive real estate to keep
costs down Dollar General tends to lease
their properties rather than buy them
and inside the stores it has a limited
selection of products that it buys in
bulk which gives the company more buying
power with suppliers most Dollar General
stores don't offer fresh produce and
compared to grocery stores have less
perishable items which have a shorter
shelf life and bring in lower margins
you walk into a Dollar General you're
gonna see metal shelves it's going to be
quite Bare Bones I think linoleum think
you know think bright lighting you won't
see a lot of people working there
by paying low wages to a minimal often
part-time staff the company keeps labor
costs low the median annual income for
employees is just over sixteen thousand
dollars according to Dollar General
Dollar General says they employ more
than a hundred and fifty seven thousand
individuals and that they offer
employees competitive wages and benefits
these stores are staffed at minimum
levels so there's not there aren't many
employees they pay closer to a gas
station attendant than even a Walmart
employee so it's people that much like
their customer base people who live in
an area where there aren't a ton of
other options
despite the name not everything costs a
dollar but prices are extremely cheap
and often significantly lower than
Grocery and drugstores
critics say Dollar General strategies
harm local communities by not providing
healthy food options and potentially
hurting the local small business economy
Dollar General says that they are not a
grocery store and that they are serving
customers that would otherwise not have
access to an affordable retail option
ultimately the low prices and the
convenience for Rural customers is what
keeps people coming back some Shoppers
have even found items for under a dollar
Penny shopping at Dollar General let's
go the first store I found Propel water
for one cent at least is the Dollar
General app scan and verify it's a penny
before heading to the register Dollar
General is on Pace to continue growing
the company grew 16 during the pandemic
a time where other retailers saw growth
in e-commerce not in-person shopping
Dollar General plans to open about a
thousand stores this year and when you
have a business model that involves
small footprint stores without a lot of
embellishments or bells and whistles a
company can do that quickly and they can
do it cheaply Dollar General is also
branching out and going in New
Directions it's been experimenting with
stocking more fresh and refrigerated
food and moving towards Urban centers it
plans to expand pop shelf a new chain
aimed at higher income Suburban
customers pop shelf in addition to being
located in different places it'll aim to
sell things that are more think of more
fun so not not as much Staples that you
need to get by day to day but things
like decorations party supplies a little
bit more fun than necessary Dollar
General says the new expansion isn't
necessarily a shift from their overall
growth strategy they say they can serve
a diverse customer base with stores in
urban Rural and Suburban locations yet
even as Dollar General expands its
offerings and Target demographics the
company expects that its core customers
will continue to be Shoppers in small
towns without other options
there really is a before and after
Sephora when it comes to the makeup
industry until about 20 years ago this
is how most Americans shop for luxury
makeup a sales representative of the
brand would stand behind the makeup
counter and help customers make a
purchase that completely changed with
Sephora now it's a free-for-all people
walk in the stores they test whatever
they want nothing is behind the glass so
how did this French retailer come to
dominate the global personal care and
beauty product industry and what
business practices helped make it the
industry leader that it is today
this is the economics of Sephora
today the beauty retailer employs over
36 000 people in more than 2 700 stores
in over 35 countries those stores carry
over 250 Beauty Brands
at this point Sephora is like kind of my
second home
the Sephora that we know today has its
roots in a small perfume shop that
opened in 1969 in Limoges France at that
time the perfume and cosmetics Market
was dominated by a service-based retail
model in which staff typically received
commissions based on sales instead
Sephora used the assisted self-service
model in which customers are free to
test products in the store we have a
full station where you can just like
literally grab whatever and you can try
on the lipsticks you can try in the
eyeshadows I always leave looking like a
literal different person than I arrived
Sephora customers can still request help
from a sales associate who Sephora calls
a beauty advisor there's a little bit
more trust with the sales
representatives in this Forest store
because they're brand agnostic so they
can tell you maybe you should buy them
mascara from this brand but you should
buy the blush from a different brand
Sephora also bucked convention in the
manner in which it displayed its
products so makeup items are next to
each other whereas from the same brand a
fragrance would be in the fragrance
aisle and the same brand a skin care
product will be in the skincare aisle
then in 1997 founder Dominic Montano
sold Sephora to the large luxury retail
conglomerate lvmh one of the advantages
of being owned by a conglomerate like
lmh is that the company can jump very
quickly on Trends and actually several
of the brands that are sold in Sephora
stores are owned by lvmh one of the
popular brands owned by lvmh is Fenty
Beauty by Rihanna and then Fenty of
course has a huge section the whole row
of Fenty we got the lip glosses up front
Sephora's success also stems from its
exclusive line of products there's a
little bit of attention in the
relationship between a store and a brand
because Sephora is such a hot store for
makeup brands to sell their products in
Sephora ends up having a lot more
leverage in that relationship the
Sephora collection the challenge for
high-end Beauty Brands these days is
that they're really facing a conundrum
they've become increasingly dependent on
Sephora for sales growth but because
alvia Mage also produces Beauty Brands
and there's an element of competition
there and more brands are coming out
constantly the shelves brace is
shrinking five Sephora products you need
to try part 10. in part due to that
product exclusivity Sephora boasts a
loyal customer base here are five
Sephora products you need to buy tonight
sorry I don't make the rules you just
have to so what you'll find oftentimes
on Instagram or Tick Tock is that people
have these haul videos where they're
showing all the products that they
bought on Sephora and they're going one
by one talking about them this is the
closest tinted face oil and it's 42. I
recommend this product to everyone and
they're always like I'm paying 42
dollars for a face oil yes you are many
faithful customers are members of
Sephora's Beauty Insider program which
has three different tiers and more than
25 million members the lowest here is
the beauty Insider later
the next level up is Vib or very
important Beauty Insider which users
must spend 350 dollars in a calendar
year to unlock the top level is called
Rouge which customers can access after
spending at least a thousand dollars in
a calendar year benefits like savings
increase with each tier I'm Rouge don't
judge me I know I spend a lot of money
okay I get it but the real Advantage for
Sephora for the beauty Rewards program
is that every time a customer goes in
there and Sephora knows exactly what
they bought and that is very valuable
information for the company to
understand who the customer is what
they're purchasing and then down the
road to be able to Market in a very
personalized way to that customer yet as
much as the company profits on
exclusivity with its products when it
comes to Sephora's consumer base the
retailer takes inclusivity seriously one
of the ways that Sephora has tried to
become more inclusive is by featuring a
larger number of brands in their stores
they made an effort to include black
owned Brands and then also so by pushing
Brands to expand their product lines and
offer products that appeal to people
from different racial groups different
ethnicities in 2021 Sephora relaunched
color IQ a skin tone matching technology
that the company offers to assist
customers in selecting the most natural
products for their skin tone
and Sephora is still expanding in
December 2020 the company announced a
partnership with the Department chain
Kohl's to install 850 shops inside coal
stores by 2023 since opening 200 Kohl's
locations this summer Sephora has added
200 000 new Beauty insiders in a
statement to the Wall Street Journal a
Sephora spokesperson said we want to be
an unequivocal Global leader in the
prestige Beauty space and a
purpose-driven brand that is a
transformative opportunity for Everyone
We Touch they continued by outlining
three main areas customers Brands and
teams sometimes when customers step out
say the Sephora store they will have
splotches of makeup all over their arms
and that really showcases what they've
been doing in the store
walk into a Target anywhere in the U.S
and you're likely to find Sleek
mannequins elaborate displays and fancy
lighting Target is very focused on the
Aesthetics of their stores their
products that is what they hope makes it
feel like an elevated Discount Store
experience this elevated experience
which has led some to nickname the store
Target is part of the company's strategy
to differentiate itself from competitors
and draw customers through the door but
what's happening in the front of a
Target store is only a portion of the
retailer secret to success
this is the economics of Target Target
to me is so interesting because really
they're a department store that became a
discount store and they were always
going after sort of a higher end
Discount Store image and that's remained
true to today Target positions itself as
the option for cheap yet Chic items and
customers can see the two ideas combined
when walking around the store
in certain areas like apparel home goods
and electronics Target stages items with
lavish lighting and displays but just
across the way you'll still find the
standard merchandise aisles with uniform
fluorescent lights target has always
tried to sort of meld these like visual
expectations that we have from a
department store like the mannequins and
the good lighting and like a display for
Cosmetics with a discount model they
also want you to feel like you're
getting a good deal and I think you see
that as they iterate on store designs
they still strive for that combination
according to a study by hawk incentives
when a customer feels like they're
getting a good deal it can make them
feel smart and in turn increase sales
don't get distracted to Target don't get
distracted at Target don't get this to
oh I need that retailers always are
looking for this balance of things that
bring you to the store that you need
like a gallon of milk and the things
that you might buy in a whim that they
actually make more money off of Target
store design is one of several factors
that have helped the retailer expand in
recent years the business has grown more
than 35 percent in the last two years
Crossing 100 billion dollars in annual
revenue driven in large part by the
pandemic and a decision Target made five
years ago to invest in its stores you
know lots of retailers said hey Amazon
is here let's stop building stores let's
remodel what we have let's develop an
e-commerce model let's invest in other
things target has continued adding
stores some of them tend to be smaller
stores different types of formats while
they've invested in e-commerce but they
haven't completely pulled back on
expanding their store account the
retailer has over 1900 locations in the
U.S which is smaller than Walmart but
bigger than Costco around 75 percent of
the US population lives within 10 miles
of one of these stores so Target like
lots of retailer established retailers
big retailers has this huge benefit
right now which is they have the stores
already and you probably live pretty
close to one and that's enabled them to
say offer things online for pickup in
the store parking lot which has been
wildly successful for them during the
pandemic because they have that store
for you to go and pick up your online
order at the majority of operations like
in-store and curbside pickup and
fulfillment for online orders get
started in the back room of the stores
it's been so interesting because they
started to say like we're going to use
our stores we're not going to build big
you know e-commerce warehouses we're
going to use our stores several years
ago and there was a little bit of
skepticism in the market because it
didn't seem like you could really be
that efficient in that model but in the
end they say they've saved a lot of
money because a they're not building a
huge Warehouse which costs a lot of
money up front and you know they already
have the trucks coming to their stores
with their goods and they're just using
those stores to the maximum possibility
last year Target's brick and mortar
locations handled more than 95 percent
of over 100 billion dollars in sales so
walk around any Target and you're likely
to see this operation in action workers
move carts throughout the store
Gathering and scanning items
While others watch for cars pulling up
and deliver their orders in effect
Target hires workers specifically for
its fulfillment operations
the company calls this role a
fulfillment expert they're either out on
the floor collecting Goods off the
shelves just like a shopper whether in
the back room packing up things into
boxes getting them labeled appropriately
they're really more like warehouse
workers and now the company is taking
this a step further in an effort to
bridge the gap between its stores and
its delivery location doing these things
called certation centers which allow
them to basically have or orders from
stores that are being packed up by
fulfillment workers sent to that more
central location but still kind of close
to stores and then picked up and sent
out from there Target success is also
strongly dependent on the items in its
stores at any given time about one-third
of Target's inventory is exclusive to
the retailer through private labels
similarly designers will often partner
with Target for a limited time capsule
collection
these capsule collections for Target are
sort of marketing right it's a way to
say hey we're High design big designers
are interested in working with us so it
gives them a little bit of that cachet
these collections are nearly as
fundamental to Target as its Bullseye
logo in the late 90s top makeup artist
Sonia kashik partnered with Target to
create a professional makeup line at
affordable prices 16 years later Target
bought the line and today this line is
only one of Target's more than 45
private labels they have become huge
brands for Target and they've added more
and more and now it's a pretty
significant percentage of their sales
and private label like at all companies
can be lower price for the consumer but
more profitable for the retailer so
there's a big interest for any retailer
going in that direction according to a
report by CB insights retailers can earn
25 to 30 percent higher gross margins on
private labels compared to manufacturer
Brands target has yet to share the
precise margin on its private labels but
currently 11 of its brands are worth at
least one billion dollars with four
brand fans crossing the 2 billion mark
while target has transitioned through
many iterations since it got its start
in 1962. changing store designs many
times and acquiring businesses within
its larger brand the company continues
to evolve with the ever-changing
customer
they tend to kind of change
strategy quickly when things aren't
working and I think we see them in the
middle of potentially another version of
that because the consumer is changing so
much right now but even as the company
evolves some aspects remain the same I
think the most consistent thing for
target has been this image this idea
that they're an elevated brand they're
different than their competitors they
have stuck with that since the beginning
and they still really lean on it today
this is a tiny home on Airbnb so far
this year this listing has brought in
over twenty thousand dollars for its
host the typical U.S host in 2021 earned
over thirteen thousand eight hundred
dollars according to the company the
tiny home doesn't cost a lot to build
and yet it could charge hundreds of
dollars a night Airbnb posted a profit
in its second quarter as guests booked a
record number of stays and experiences
and hosts increase prices for rentals
amid High inflation but people didn't
book as much as analysts had projected
and the company's summer bookings
forecast fell short of expectations
obviously it's an incredibly Dynamic
period of time but I'm still expecting
an incredibly strong period of travel
even if people pull back spending some
so how did the largest Home Sharing
platform in the U.S navigate its biggest
crises and could it borrow those lessons
to weather fears of a recession this is
the economics of Airbnb
Airbnb started around the time of the
2008 financial crisis this was a time
when people were really hard hit by the
recession and they were looking for a
way to make an extra buck in 2016 the
company launched Airbnb experiences
which led Travelers book classes tours
and outings Airbnb also spent more as it
grew the CEO branched out into all kinds
of things like he wanted to have a media
Studios he wanted to Branch into
transportation and then the pandemic hit
business was down 80 percent forcing
Airbnb to take on two billion dollars in
debt and pause all non-essential
projects I hope I never do a side
project again in my life I learned a
lesson I think the lesson is when you
try to do new things the side things
they don't work summer of 2020 was a
turning point for Airbnb people started
quarantining with their families friends
started taking staycations while they
could work remote so that's something
that definitely benefited Airbnb local
travel became its strong hold and people
started using the platform for longer
stays the company was one of the hottest
public listings of 2020 though its stock
price has fallen since then amid a broad
Market cool off in August Airbnb
projected record third quarter revenue
on the back of higher rental prices and
said it expects to post its first
full-year profit this year
a lot of businesses have lucky moments
but there's something to be said about
getting lucky and also being able to
ride that wave and capitalize on it
that's what Airbnb says it has done from
the start back then in 2008 a lot of
people turned to hosting because they
were losing their homes housing prices
and a lot of people because they didn't
have as much money were looking for more
affordable ways to travel than ever
before that really helped them bring a
lot of people who were looking for ways
to make up for lost income onto the
platform and you can really see them
capitalize on timing during the pandemic
as well Airbnb redesigned its app and
website to focus on local stays during
the pandemic last summer it launched a
flexible search feature which curates
trips for people who don't know where
they want to go the pandemic and remote
work gave us that flexibility you know
we could travel during the week and
still work remote so Airbnb starts
noticing this trend and it says oh my
God we can you know we can sort of
utilize on this and they do in May
Airbnb launched another redesign of its
Search tool that split homes into more
than 50 categories as a way to steer
people to places they wouldn't otherwise
have picked so what they're trying to do
is they're trying to fill existing homes
instead of adding more and more homes
some analysts say this is key to the
company's future growth since Global
occupancy rates are low
when it comes to addressing safety
issues on its platform some cities have
complained that Airbnb has been too
hands off they're not actively
monitoring these properties because
frankly they can't they don't own them
so that's really where a lot of their
problems stem from four people killed
another fur heard all of it happening in
a house rented out on Airbnb after a
2019 Halloween shooting the company
announced safety measures including a 24
7 neighborhood hotline to field
complaints we've banned all parties
globally on Airbnb we have a risky
reservation queue where we're looking at
any suspicious activity and we have a
pretty Hands-On team that's using some
pretty Advanced like machine learning
technology to essentially identify
anything we think is suspicious if it is
we'll continue to seek more information
the company says the number of Party
complaints have dropped 44 percent in
the last two years Airbnb has also been
trying to reduce that rate further by
doing things like blocking one or two
night stays on New Year's Eve and
Halloween for guests without a history
of positive review use but instance keep
happening earlier this year we had a
shooting in Pittsburgh and again you
know people were injured City officials
have also blamed Airbnb for ruining the
long-term rental market in some small
communities what's happened is a lot of
people are just snapping up properties
and renting them and as a result locals
don't have enough properties to rent
long term Airbnb doesn't think that it's
actually affected the long-term rental
market but you know if you ask uh City
officials they have a different story
for example in 2020 the mayor of Sedona
Arizona a tourist hotspot said that the
demand for Airbnb rentals worsened the
shortage of affordable housing and
demolished the long-term rental market
if we are you know part of the problem
we are going to work with cities we've
that's why we've done numerous
agreements of cities to create
restrictions we actually do want Airbnb
to get more and more into long-term
housing we want people to really feel
invested in Community one of the things
that Airbnb is doing now is it's trying
to direct people to areas where it has
Supply and that sort of also takes the
load off of certain places that that
everyone might go to and that might get
sort of overburdened in April Airbnb
announced that its employees can work
from almost anywhere without a pay cut
so if more businesses do follow airbnb's
lead
Airbnb stands to gain in its home rental
business because that would mean more
digital Nomads more people traveling and
likely booking more airbnbs but some
Travelers are concerned about Rising
nightly rates and some analysts believe
that hotel chains and competitors like
Expedia group stand to gain as business
travel picks up this year so the
question is can Airbnb keep up the
momentum we're an incredibly lean
company we've already been preparing for
a storm that what we thought was
inevitable for years to come Airbnb
dramatically cut costs during the
pandemic and analysts have credited the
company for keeping those down even as
travel rebounded while a potential
economic downturn could decrease demand
Airbnb says it could also bring more
hosts to the platform as the economy is
going to be slowing down I think more
and more people are going to be
interested in saving money and I think
they're also going to be interested in
new ways to make money and unlike hotels
with fixed
fixed lighting properties that serve
Travelers changing needs like it did
during the switch to local travel I
think even as we're entering recession
people have been kind of isolated for
years and they're yearning to get out
and the one thing I think you're going
to see them spend money on is they're
going to continue to travel
if you've ever seen a commercial for the
Home Depot you might be familiar with
this tune it's a good time to be a doer
Home Depot and its theme song have
inspired a wave of videos on social
media
revealing its cultural status as the
go-to Home Improvement store for many
during the pandemic
Home Depot is the world's largest Home
Improvement retailer with over 2 300
stores across North America what we've
seen is home price appreciation and
housing activity at unprecedented levels
and what we know is that when homes
become more valuable those homeowners
are more willing to spend on them with
its 2021 fiscal year sales larger than
both Lowe's and Ace Hardware combined
one of Home Depot's biggest advantages
is its foothold in the professional
customer space that is electricians
remodelers plumbers and other Home
professionals that place more lucrative
orders so how exactly has Home Depot
attracted more professional customers
and what other strategies have helped it
become a leader in the Home Improvement
retail industry
this is the economics of Home Depot
walk into a Home Depot you'll see a huge
floor space dozens of long aisles with
everything from screws and other
Hardware to tools to major appliances
garden supplies doors windows toilets
really anything you need for a home
improvement project a typical Home Depot
store stocks about thirty thousand to
forty thousand items throughout the year
most locations are around one hundred
four thousand square feet the scale of
the store gives customers the
opportunity to buy raw materials in bulk
and pick up items quickly they try to be
somewhere that you can go if you're just
an individual trying to fix up something
in your kitchen they also try to be a
place that you can go if you're a
contractor trying to buy lumber to help
renovate somebody's home or if you're a
plumber that needs all kinds of pipe
fittings so they really try to be a good
source on both sides of that equation
Home Depot began when co-founders Bernie
Marcus and Arthur Blank were fired from
a home improvement company called handy
dance they wanted to launch a store that
would be significantly bigger and
cheaper than competitors in 1979 they
opened their first two Home Depot
locations in Atlanta the Home Depot the
founders had a vision for a home
improvement retailer that could be a
One-Stop shop for the DIY or do
do-it-yourself customer you've never
seen anything like it the Home
Improvement customer to us is unique
they're a doer that's where that word
comes from since its founding Home Depot
has grown into a multi-billion dollar
company that increasingly caters to the
professional contractor as well as the
DIY consumer while many Industries like
service and Hospitality took a hit
during the pandemic Home Depot's Revenue
continued to grow the pandemic fueled a
boom in the Home Improvement industry as
people spent more time and money on
remodeling projects but between middle
of 2020 in the middle of 2021 there were
four straight quarters where Home Depot
grew its sales by more than 20 percent
year over year which is a very fast pace
for a large established company Home
Depot says they are seeing increasing
demand for professional projects as
people feel comfortable inviting
contractors back into their homes
there's been this buildup of projects
that require professionals that more
recently people have been willing to get
to and that's sort of led to a second
wind of sales growth what kind of person
would come here at 5 45 a.m well there's
Carly a carpenter Home Depot has
positioned itself to attract more
business from these contractors and home
professionals particularly ones that
place big orders everything we do
in the 2021 fiscal year about 50 percent
of its sales came from Pro customers
even though they made up less than 10
percent of its customer base in
comparison about 20 to 25 percent of
Lowe's total sales come from Pro
customers according to the company as a
key part of its Pro customer strategy
Home Depot has invested 1.2 billion
dollars in expanding its supply chain
and distribution Network the company
says it is building 150 new distribution
centers to help speed up the
replenishment of store shelves and
quickly deliver purchases to customers
doors each facility with some as large
as about 14 professional football fields
can hold a huge amount of inventory and
deliver orders directly to a project
site one thing we know that's important
to our Pros is delivery of product to
the job site we've shifted our model to
a network of nearly 150 distribution
centers that are engineered to deliver
those big and bulky products that are
unique to the Home Depot and unique to
the pro think Lumber think doors think
Windows think vanities we're designing a
network that will deliver those goods
same day or next day to 90 percent of
the population in our Market the Home
Improvement Giants distribution network
works in tandem with their online
strategy giving Pro customers more
flexible options that better align with
busy schedules we're one of the largest
e-commerce retailers in the country by
volume when people come to pick up
orders from our lockers or from our
service desk they often shop for more
products in the store and so that's an
economic flywheel that our website
creates for our company these
possibilities have really helped the
company grow its sales quite a bit over
the last two years sales from e-commerce
channels have gone up by about a hundred
percent so basically doubled though Home
Depot has seen a long period of
consistent Revenue growth the Home
Improvement retail space remains a
competitive and fragmented Market this
is a space where customers are very
sensitive to prices so if one brand is
charging a higher price for a certain
type of equipment that's something that
buyers could pick up on and could easily
shift to another retailer so Home Depot
is definitely very sensitive to other
big chains to smaller mom and pop stores
the industry is also sensitive to
economic fluctuations especially with
spending Trends tied to the housing
market going back to the Great Recession
and the financial crisis 10 years ago
that was a very difficult time for Home
Improvement retailers a turbulent period
for Home Depot in the last couple years
during the pandemic that housing
Market's been very strong certainly a
company that would be in a very
different position if there was some
kind of big downturn in the housing
market in general
foreign